76
of the world population live in urban
areas
cities and human settlements are still
growing and it is certain that most of
the challenges faced by humankind will
happen there
monitoring the developments and health
of our big planet and its inhabitants
requires mapping
and comparison of all places to develop
relevant infrastructure
and services in a densely populated area
the way urban and rural areas are
defined influences how urban and rural
population is accounted this is
essential to identify best practices and
improvements in policy making
the degree of urbanization is a method
to capture the full spectrum of
settlements from the hamlet to the
megacity
satellites can be used to map the
presence of buildings on earth
we will learn how to classify polygons
that correspond to senses
administrative or statistical units
according to the degree of urbanization
this way sdg-related and general
statistics requiring urban and rural
disaggregation will be comparable across
countries to tell the new stories and
drive the strategies of the future
leaving no one behind
[Music]
you